I was having a conversation with a
famous YouTuber who is known for
sacrificing all of his time and doing
everything like monk mode no girlfriend
and he called me up and he was like you
can maintain your muscle mass without
working out that much why do you work
out so much shouldn't you be taking all
that extra time and working more on
getting to a billion dollars the answer
is no under that same assumption okay
well then having kids is something
that's going to make you poor but with
most people if you have kids you make
more money part of that is because you
have more mouths to feed so you force
yourself to make more money the other
reason is that if you think all the way
at the top of the wealth pyramid look at
besos look at musk look at Bill Gates
look at Warren Buffett every single one
of them not only have one kid but
multiple children if it were true that
having kids or working out were
something that we're going to cost you
well in the long term then the people
who are at the top of the pyramid
wouldn't have those things which means
the premise is false you do have to work
to a certain point and then after you
have a certain amount of work that you
are able to put in the leverage or how
much you get out of the work that you
put in becomes the big multiplier